sorry what I'm just taking some pictures
of this scratch okay okay but okay but
we're not scratched here
you are to my car you
can't you look
okay
I'm in the bay yeah you're not in your
bait I don't care you have scratched my
card when I parked this car there was no
scratch on it he can't scratch your car
because his car is so low he's gonna
scratch through tires lady
it's on the top of the fender
he's just being a whole ass Karen right
now this is Karen Behavior yeah not me
this looks like scammer Behavior it's
Karen
scammering Hey listen something like
that hey this looks like skin I've seen
ploys like these that's really Karen
yeah that's that's really the audacity
of a girl this is just oh you're so
close to me or whatever yeah it's a mix
of both I was in it it's invisible so
he's a scam this is a scammer stuff
because it if if you're saying she
didn't do it
because like this is like almost a meme
in Japan there's people who like let me
throw themselves in front of cars but
I'm not saying she didn't do it I'm
saying that's not where it happened
you're offended because you cannot go in
your car but you're the one that's wrong
because you're not in your lines right
oh can you feel like he's offended she
can't get in her car she can't get in
the car she's trying to get back at him
but she's the one in the wrong okay you
know what I mean yeah so so it's
something that is she didn't she was not
looking for someone to scam that's a
scratch that's a scratch whatever it is
what it is okay she doesn't drive good
so car's too big for her it's just that
she couldn't get in the car well then
you scratched it because you're too
close to my car learn how to [__]
Park your whole ass Wheels over the side
of the line and not by little by a lot
and then learn how to [__] park now
sometimes you park that way because the
car on the other side forces you to park
that way that's not what you said though
I'm just saying I'm just saying hey I've
seen that before yeah well there's one
[__] so it makes everyone else
[__] right yeah absolutely but it
kind of looked like you is the only
[__] present you're the [__] and
nobody's playing along so you mad but
I'm saying your insurance state house as
well yeah yeah I'm taking a picture of
your number plate no but like what I'm
saying yeah if there's a scratching your
car how come there's not a scratch a
marker
if the glove don't fit you must have
quit
I'm in the bay you're not in the bay
you're gonna see the mark on this side
exactly exactly
when I when I what is that yeah no car's
not big enough to scratch the heart
that's right move along
Hey listen if the glove don't fit you a
dumb [__] congrats on this car I'm
still taking the pictures you hit the
pictures but like I'm not giving you no
details like like I'm not here I don't
care you don't need to give me details I
can get all your details from your
insurance
there's no scratch on my car though
Kings who would be like you take a look
take a look uh lady we just checked the
front of the car there's no scratches
anywhere
how does one car scratch another car and
only one of them come out with dents and
[__]
can you care to explain because this
motherfucker's car made a titanium alloy
like the paint is going to scratch it's
cuff it's gonna be something that we
call a transfer Bank Tell them
I've been scuffed oh you've always been
the victim so you're trying to say
that's why I got a whole ass uh dash cam
on my [__] you know huh front and back
to catch you doing the crime or catch
other people doing it yeah I would catch
myself doing the crime
but you said nobody needs to know but
you shut the [__] up everybody
[Music]
trust me I'm a sweaty [__] if I
swear she sweats that's whether she want
to or not it is what it is so so yeah
there's a pain transfer and that's not
happening so yeah yeah
I lie
I think it's a polo wedding from I I
like how a bunch of guys have just
showed up and they'd be like nah because
you lying and finally you know what she
turned it around shout outs to her at
least she admitted you know what I I
think uh maybe yeah you [__] up you
got mad for a reason you're not mad at
least she admitted it but no if that was
fresh you'd see a little bit of pain
pill that's not fair for a while and
then like you're over here trying to
accuse yourself of doing it you need you
you know you know that's been there
before isn't it yeah you you said yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
you too lady but you pain
like I said YouTube
this ain't a Karen thing she's a scammer
she tried to scam them I think it's a
scary thing it really is she got
triggered and all the guys de-escalated
that thing I really think what do you
mean shot triggered she knew that that
[__] was there before the way you were
so she was trying to put it on him to
get some claim that's a scammer he was
I'm not saying no I agree with you the
fact that she scam but it didn't came
the thing is as camera looks for that
you understand what I'm saying I'm gonna
look to the intention is that well the
difference is in that particular case is
that she got to a car this [__]
was close even though she was the one
that was not parked properly you know he
was in his line she's like you know what
whatever she I believe that she got to a
car and then they got to the same spot
and
she don't want to be accused of parking
like a piece of [__] so she's gonna be
like you create my car you scratched my
car she went to that okay that [__]
happened so much so yes you are right
with the fact that I'm gonna take all
your information and if this and that
blah blah whatever whatnot which you
probably wouldn't have gone through all
the way right but I think she got
triggered because she was there and he
was there okay meeting that they got to
their car approximately at the same time
and she didn't want to get accused of
being like a piece of chicken yeah okay
I drive bad but you scratched my car you
try and try to avoid all the things like
yeah I parked I parked okay I don't know
how to pause but hey no forget what you
want you're not gonna blame me or
nothing I'm a grown ass woman you
scratched my car ain't you I've seen
this Behavior so much that's why women
I've seen that and I'm not gonna say
it's white woman I'm gonna say I've seen
that am I wrong I thought Karen's for
white women before it was now anybody
could be a character anybody could be a
cat I've seen but it's mostly white I
gotta admit it's mostly white but a lot
of people a lot of I've seen I've seen
being caring behaviors are out of a lot
of people you know what I mean and then
they they they do that they do that they
do the most and then after that when you
de-escalate with all the you gotta
numerous people being like nah nah we're
pointing the facts then it kind of
de-escalate the person the person ain't
got she's running out of options
that person has a scammer he would have
taken information and
you know that was not the information
that was not the intention in the first
place but she still it's her Pride got
hurt so her Pride her Pride got hurt
okay what happened with the pride she
went the pride went to scamming okay
okay but that was not the intention okay
she was she's gonna live with that
scratch her whole life she doesn't care
she got money her anything in that bus
crash she don't care she probably rubbed
it off a post or something like that
trying to blame it on someone's pride
it's Pride
got you what there you guys have it what
y'all think Karen scammer a little bit
of both let us know in the comment
anything else you want to say nah let us
know what you guys think in the comments
below we want to hear from you
scattering